no words necessary ladies and gentlemen
it gives me very particular pleasure to
introduce Patti Smith hello everyone
just have to put on my spectacles
Herman HESA won the Nobel Prize for
Literature in 1946 I decided to read an
excerpt from his masterwork Magister
Ludi only last night during the Nobel
Prize concert as I was very moved by the
solo violinist the orchestra performing
Beethoven's Pastoral and the closing
words of the conductor the novel traces
the life of one of the glass bead game's
greatest Magisters Joseph necked the
first passage tells of his youthful
meeting with a venerable music master do
you happen to know what a fugue is the
master asked Joseph had already heard
fugues but had not studied them in class
very well the master said then I'll show
you
you'll grasp it quicker if we make a
fugue ourselves he played a brief
passage a fragment of a songs melody the
boy looked at the clever white fingers
saw the course of the development
faintly mirrored in the Masters
concentrated expression while his eyes
remained quiet under half closed lids
Joseph's heart swelled with veneration
with love for the master his ears drank
in the fugue it seemed to him that he
was hearing music for the first time in
his life behind the music being created
in his presence he sensed the world of
mind the joy giving harmony of law and
freedom of service and rule he
surrendered himself and vowed to serve
that world and this master in those few
minutes he saw himself in his life so
the whole cosmos guided ordered and
interpreted by the spirit of music
the old man slowly raised himself from
The Pianist tool fix those blue eyes
piercingly with unimaginable
friendliness upon him and said making
music together is the best way for two
people to become friends there is none
easier that is a fine thing I hope you
and I shall become friends years later
when Joseph rose himself to become the
great master of the glass bead game he
visited the music master shortly before
he died this is how he describes it you
are tiring yourself Joseph the music
master said softly and at that moment he
laid his hand upon my arm it was light
as a butterfly and he looked into my
eyes and smiled at that moment I was
conquered something of his cheerful
silence something of his patience and
calm passed into me and I suddenly
understood the old man and the direction
his nature had taken away from people
and towards silence away from words and
toward music away from ideas and toward
unity and for the first time grasped the
meaning of his smile his radiance
I cannot communicate to you what went on
between us or what was exchanged
certainly no words were spoken I felt
him and the course of his growth from
the time he first entered my life when I
was a boy up to this present moment his
was a life of devotion and work but free
of obstructions free of ambition and
full of music it was if by becoming a
muse
ition and music master he had chosen
music as one of the ways towards man's
highest goal inner freedom purity
perfection and as though ever since
making that choice he had done nothing
but let himself be more and more
permeated transformed and purified by
music his entire self from his pianist
hands and his vast musician's memory to
all the body and soul to his pulses and
breathing to his sleep and dreaming so
that he was now a manifestation a
personification of music I experienced
what radiated from him or what surged
back and forth between him and me like
rhythmatic breathing entirely of as
music which absorbs everyone who enters
its magic circle as a song from many
voices absorbs an entering voice perhaps
a non musician would have perceived this
grace in different images an astronomer
and astronomer might have seen it as a
moon circling around a planet or a
philologist heard it as some magical
primal language containing all meanings
I was wing in heaven blue
on the ocean sword in the rain and I was
free honey nobody it was beautiful it
was beautiful I was an image in another
eye and I saw nothing no future at all
yet I was free I needed nobody it was
beautiful it was beautiful
and if there's one thing could do for
you
you'd be a wing in heaven blue and if
there's one thing could do for you
oh you'd be a wing in heaven blue thank
you
[Applause]